all right today I want to talk about bit
more about fault tolerance and
replication and then look into the
details of today's paper about vmware ft
the topics still fault tolerance to
provide high availability that is you
want to build a server that even if some
hardware you know computer crashes is
involved in the service we still like to
provide the service and to the extent we
can we'd like to provide our service
also if there's network problems and the
tool we're using its replication least
for this part of the course so it's
worth asking what kind of failures
replication can be expected to deal with
because it's not everything by any means
so maybe the easiest way to characterize
the kind of failures we're talking about
is fail stop failures of a single
computer and what I mean by fail stop
it's a sort of generic term and fault
tolerance is that if something goes
wrong would say the computer the
computer simply stops executing it just
stops if anything goes wrong and in
particular it doesn't compute incorrect
results so if somebody kicks the power
cable out of your server that's probably
gonna generate a fail stop failure
similarly if they unplug your servers
network connection even though the
server is still running so this is a
little bit funny you know be totally cut
off from the network so it looks at me
outside like it just stopped so it's
really these failures we can deal with
with replication this also covers some
hardware problems like you know maybe if
the fan on your server breaks because it
you know it cost 50 cents maybe that'll
cause the CPU to overheat and the CPU
will shut itself down cleanly and just
stop executing
what's not covered by the kind of
replication systems we're talking about
is things like bugs and software or
design defects in hardware so basically
not bugs because if we take some service
you know say you're a MapReduce master
for example you know we replicated and
run it on two computers you know if
there's a bug in your MapReduce master
or my MapReduce master let's say
replications not going to help us we're
going to compute the same incorrect
result on both of our copies of our
MapReduce master and everything looked
fine they'll agree you just happen to be
the wrong answer so we can't depending
against bugs in the replicated software
and we can't defend against bugs in the
whatever scheme we're using to manage
the replication and similarly as I
mentioned before we can't expect to deal
with bugs in the hardware the hardware
it computes incorrectly that's just
that's the end for us at least with this
kind of technique although you know that
said there are definitely hardware and
software bugs that that replication
might if you're lucky might be able to
cope it so if there's some unrelated
software running in your server and it
causes the server to crash maybe because
your kernel to panic and reboot or
something it has nothing to do with you
know with your with the service you're
replicating then that kind of failure
for us for your service will may well be
fail stop
you know the kernel will panic and the
backup replicas will take over similarly
some kinds of hardware errors can be
turned into fail stop errors for example
if you send a packet over the network
and the network corrupts it just flips a
bit in your packet that will almost
certainly be caught by the checksum on
the packet same thing for a disk block
if you write some data to disk and weand
it back a month later you know maybe the
magnetic surface isn't perfect and you
know one of the best couple of bits were
wrong in the block as it's right back
it's actually error correcting
that up to a certain point will fix
errors in disk blocks that you'll be
turning you know random hardware errors
into as either correcting them if you're
super lucky or at least detecting them
and turning random corruption into a
detected fault which you know the
software then knows that something that
wrong and can turn it into a fail stop
fault by stopping executing or take some
other remedial action but in general we
really can only expect to handle fail
stop faults there's other limits to
replication to you know the the failures
in the if we have a primary in the back
of our two replicas or whatever we're
really assuming that failures in the two
are independent right if there tend to
have correlated failures then
replication is not going to help us so
for example if we're a big outfit and we
buy thousands of computers batches of
thousands of computers identical
computers from the same manufacturer and
we run you know our replicas is on all
on those computers we bought at the same
time from the same place that's a bit of
a risk
maybe because presumably if one of them
has a manufacturing defect in it there's
a good chance that the other ones do too
you know one of them's prone to
overheating because the manufacturer you
know didn't provide enough airflow well
it probably all had that problem and so
one of them overheats and dies it's a
good chance that the other ones will too
so that's one kind of correlated failure
you just have to be careful of another
one is that you know if there's an
earthquake and the city where our
datacenter is probably gonna take out
the whole data center you know we can
have all the replication we like inside
that data center it's not going to help
us because the failure caused by an
earthquake or a citywide power failure
or something the building burning down
is like it's correlated failure between
our replicas if they're on that building
so if we care about dealing with
earthquakes then we need to put our
replicas in maybe in just different
cities at least physically separate
enough that they have separate power
unlikely to be affected by the same
natural disaster
okay but that's all sort of hovering in
the background for this discussion where
we're talking about the technology you
might use another question about
replication is whether it's worthwhile
you may ask yourself gosh you know this
literally uses these replication schemes
use twice as much or three times as much
computer resources right we need to have
you know GFS had three copies of every
box we have to buy three times as much
disk space the paper for today
you know replicates just once but that
means we have twice as many computers
and CPUs and RAM it's all for expensive
like is that really worth it that
expense and you know that's not
something we can answer technically
right it's an economic question it
depends on the value of having an
available service you know if you're
running a bank and if the consequence is
the computer failing is that your
customer you can't serve your customers
and you can't generate revenue and your
customers all hate you then it may well
be worth it to blow you know an extra
ten or twenty thousand bucks on a second
computer so you can have a replica on
the other hand if you're me and you're
running the 684 web server I don't
consider it worthwhile to have a hot
backup of the 84 web server because the
consequences of failure are very low so
the whether the replication is
worthwhile on how many replicas you
ought to have and how much you're
willing to spend on it is all about how
much cost and inconvenience failure
would call it cause you all right this
paper sort of in the beginning mentions
as there's a couple of different
approaches to replication really
mentions two one two calls state
transfer and the other calls replicated
state machine most of the schemes we're
going to talk about in this class are
replicated state machines
it'll talk about both anyway the idea
behind state transferor's that if we
have two replicas of a server the way
you cause them to be to stay in sync
that is to be actual replicas so that
the backup can has everything it needs
to take over if the primary fails in a
state transfer scheme the way that works
is that the primary sends a copy of its
entire state that is for example the
contents of its RAM to the backup and
the backup just sort of stores the
latest state and so it's all there
the primary fails in the backup can
start executing with this last state it
got if the primary fails so this is all
about sending the state of the of the
primary and for today's if today's paper
worked as a state transfer system which
it doesn't then the state we'd be
talking about would be the contents of
the RAM the contents of the memory of
the primary so maybe every once while
the primary would just you know make a
big copy of its memory and send it
across the network to the backup you can
imagine if you wanted to be efficient
you know maybe you would only send the
parts of the memory that it's changed
since the last time you sent in memory
to the backup the replicated state
machine
this approach observes that most
services are most computer things we
want to replicate have some internal
operation that's deterministic except
when external input comes in right you
know ordinarily if there's no external
influences on a computer it just
executes one instruction after another
and what each instruction does is a
deterministic function of what's in the
memory and the registers of the computer
and it's only when external events
intervene that something unexpected may
happen like a packet arrives of a some
random time and that causes the server
to start doing something differently I'm
so replicated state machine schemes
don't send the state between the
replicas instead they just send those
external events they just send maybe
from a primary to a backup again just
send things like arriving input from the
outside world that the backup needs to
know
and the observation is that you know if
you have to two computers and they start
from the same state and they see the
same inputs that that in the same order
or at the same time the two computers
will continue to be replicas of each
other and sort of execute identically as
long as they both see the same inputs at
the same time so this transfers probably
memory and this transfer some primary
backup just operations from clients or
external external inputs or external
events and you know the reason why
people tend to favor a replicated state
machine is that usually operations are
smaller than the state but this you know
the state of a server if it's a database
server might be the entire database
might be you know gigabytes whereas the
operations are just some clients sending
and you know please read or write key 27
operations are usually small the states
usually large so replicate a state
machine usually looks attractive and
slight downside is that the schemes tend
to be quite a bit more complicated and
rely on sort of more assumptions about
how the computers operate whereas this
is a really heavy-handed I'm just gonna
send you my whole state sort of a
nothing to worry about
any questions about these strategies yes
well the did ok so the question is
suppose something went wrong with our
scheme and the backup was not actually
identical to the primary so you know
you're suppose we were running GFS
master and it's the primary it just
handed out at least two chunks server
one but because the two you know because
we've allowed the states of the primary
back to drift out of sync the backup did
not issue at least to anybody it wasn't
even away or anybody had asked for these
so now the primary thinks you know
chunks everyone has lease for some chunk
in the backup doesn't the primary fails
backup takes over right now chunks over
one thinks it has a lease for some chunk
but then the current master doesn't and
is happy to hand out the lease to some
other trunk server now we have to chunk
servers serving the same beasts okay so
that's just a close to home example but
really you know almost any bad thing and
kind of I think you construct any bad
scenario by just imagining some service
that confuse the wrong answer because
the state's leverage
so you're asking about randomization
yeah oh y'all talk about this I'll talk
about this a bit later on but it is good
that the replicated state scheme
definitely makes the most sense when the
instructions that the primary in the
back of our executing do the same thing
as long as there's no external events
right and that's almost true right you
know for an add instruction or something
yeah you know if the starting if the
registers of memory of the same and they
both execute an add instruction they had
insurgents kind of the same inputs in
the same outputs but they're in some
instructions as you point out that don't
like maybe there's an instruction that
gets the current time of day now
probably be executed at slightly
different times or an instruction that
gets the current processors unique ID
and a serial number it's going to yield
the different answers and the the the
uniform answered the questions that
sound like this is that the primary does
it and sends the answer to the backup
and the backup does not execute that
instruction but instead at the point
where it would execute that instruction
it listens for the primary to tell it
what the right answer would be and just
sort of fakes that answer to the
software I'll talk about you know how
the VMware scheme does that okay
interestingly enough though today's
paper is all about a replicated state
machine you may have noticed that
today's paper only deals with you know
processors and it's not that clear how
it could be extended to a multi-core and
a multi-core machine where the
interleavings of the instructions from
the two cores organ are
non-deterministic all right so we no
longer have this situation on a
multi-core machine where if we just let
the primary and backup execute they're
you know all else being equal they're
going to be the same because they won't
execute on multiple cores VMware has
since come out with a new possibly
completely different replication system
that does work on multi-core and the new
system appears to me to be using state
transfer instead of replicated state
machine because state transferred is
more robust in the face
multi-core and parallelism if you use
the machine and send the memory over you
know that the memory image is just that
just is the state of the machine and
sort of it doesn't matter that there was
parallelism whereas the replicated state
machine scheme really has a problem with
the parallelism you know on the other
hand I'm guessing that this new
multi-core scheme is more expensive okay
all right so if we want to build a
replicated state machine scheme we got a
number of questions to answer so we need
to decide at what level we're gonna
replicate state right so what state what
do we mean by state we have to worry
about how how closely synchronized the
primary and backup have to be right
because it's likely the primary will
execute a little bit ahead of the backup
after all it it's the primary that sees
the inputs so the backup almost
necessarily must lag over that gives
that means there's an opportunity if the
primary fails for the prime for the
backup not to be fully caught up having
the backup actually executes really in
lockstep with the primaries for
expensive because it requires a lot of
chitchat so a lot of designs a lot of
what people sweat about is how close the
synchronization is if the primary fails
or you know actually if the backup fails
to but it's more exciting if the primary
fails there has to be some scheme for
switching over and the clients have to
know oh gosh I instead of talking to the
old primary on server one I should now
be talking to the
the backup on server to all the clients
have to somehow figure this out the
switch over almost certainly it's almost
impossible maybe impossible to design a
cut over system in which no anomalies
are every are ever visible you know in
this sort of ideal world if the primary
feels we'd like nobody to ever notice
none of the clients to notice turns out
that's basically unattainable so there's
going to be a mama leaves during the cut
over and we've gotta figure out a way to
cope with them and finally if the one of
the two if one of our replicas fails we
really need to have a new replica right
if we have a two replicas and one fails
we're just living on borrowed time right
because the second replica may fail at
some point so we absolutely need to get
a new replica back online as fast as
possible so and that can be very
expensive the state is big you know you
know but the reason we like to replicate
a state machine was because we thought
state transfer would be expensive but
the two replicas in a replicated state
machine still need to have full state
right we just had a cheap way of keeping
them both in sync if we need to create a
new replica we actually have no choice
but state transfer to create the new
replicas the new replica needs to have a
complete copy of the state so it's going
to be expensive to create new replicas
and this is often people spending well
actually people spend a lot of time
worrying about all these questions and
you know we'll see them again as we look
at other replicated state machine
schemes so on the topic of what state to
replicate the today's paper has a very
interesting answer to this question it
replicates the full state of the machine
that is all of memory and all the
Machine registers it's like a very very
detailed replication scheme just no
difference at the even of the lowest
levels between the primary in the backup
that's quite rare for replication
schemes
almost always you see something that's
more like GFS where GFS absolutely did
not replicate you know they had
replication but it wasn't replicating
every single you know bit of memory
between the primaries and the backups
it was replicating much more application
level table of chunks
I had this abstraction of you know
chunks and chunk identifiers and that's
what it was replicating it wasn't
replicating sort of everything else
wasn't going to the expense of
replicating every single other thing
that machines we're doing okay as long
as they had the same sort of application
visible set of of chunks so most
replication schemes out there go the GFS
route in fact almost everything except
pretty much this paper and a few handful
of similar systems almost everything
uses application at some level
application level of replication because
it can be much more efficient because we
don't have to go to the we don't have to
go to the trouble of for example making
sure that interrupts occur at exactly
the same point in the execution of the
primary and backup GFS does not sweat
that at all but this paper has to do
because it replicates at such a low
level so most people build efficient
systems with applications specific
replication the consequence of that
though is that the replication has to be
built into the right into the
application right if you're getting a
feed of application level operations for
example you really need to have the
application participate in that because
some generic replication thing like
today's paper
doesn't really can't understand the
semantics of what needs to be replicated
so anyways so most teams are application
specific like GFS and every other paper
we're going to read on this topic
today's paper is unique in that it
replicates at the level of the machine
and therefore does not care what
software you run on it right it
replicates the low-level memory and
machine registers you can run any
software you like on it as long as it
runs on that kind of microprocessor
that's being represented this
replication scheme applies to the
software can be anything
and you know the downside is that it's
not that efficient necessarily the
upside is that you can take any existing
piece of software maybe you don't even
have source code for it or understand
how it works and you know do within some
limits you can just run it under this
under VMware this replication scheme and
it'll just work which is sort of magic
fault-tolerance wand for arbitrary
software all right now let me talk about
how this is VMware or Ft first of all
VMware is a virtual machine company
they're what their business is a lot of
their business is selling virtual
machine technology and what virtual
machines refer to is the idea of you
know you buy a single computer and
instead of booting an operating system
like Linux on the hardware you boot
we'll call a virtual machine monitor or
hypervisor on the hardware and the
hypervisor is job is actually to
simulate multiple multiple computers
multiple virtual computers on this piece
of hardware so the virtual machine
monitor may boot up you know one
instance of Linux may be multiple
instances of Linux may be a Windows
machine you can the virtual machine
monitor on this one computer can run a
bunch of different operating systems you
know each of these as is itself some
sort of operating system kernel and then
applications so this is the technology
they're starting with and you know the
reason for this is that if you know you
need to it just turns out there's many
many reasons why it's very convenient to
kind of interpose this level of
indirection between the hardware and the
operating systems and means that we can
buy one computer and run lots of
different operating systems on it we can
have each if we run lots and lots of
little services instead of having to
have lots and lots of computers one per
service you can just buy one computer
and run each service in the operate
system that it needs I'm using his
personal machines so this was their
starting point they already had this
stuff and a lot of sophisticated things
built around it at the start of
designing vmware ft so this is just
virtual machines um what the papers
doing is that it's gonna set up one
machine or they did requires two
physical machines because there's no
point in running the primary and backup
software in different virtual machines
on the same physical machine because
we're trying to guard against hardware
failures so you're gonna to at least you
know you have two machines running their
virtual machine monitors and the primary
it's going to run on one the backups and
the other so on one of these machines we
have a guest you know we only it might
be running a lot of virtual machines we
only care about one of them it's gonna
be running some guest operating system
and some sort of server application
maybe a database server MapReduce master
or something so I'll call this the
primary and there'll be a second machine
that you know runs the same virtual
machine monitor and an identical virtual
machine holding the backup so we have
the same whatever the operating system
is exactly the same and the virtual
machine is you know giving these guest
operating systems the primary and backup
a each range of memory and this memory
images will be identical or the goal is
to make them identical in the primary in
the backup we have two physical machines
each one of them running a virtual
machine guest with a its own copy of the
service we care about we're assuming
that there's a network connecting these
two machines and in addition on this
local area network in addition on this
network there's some set of clients
really they don't have to be clients
they're just maybe other computers that
our replicated service needs to talk
with some of them our clients
sending requests it turns out in this
paper there the replicated service
actually doesn't use a local disk and
instead assumes that there's some sort
of disk server that it talks to him
although it's a little bit hard to
realize this from the paper the scheme
actually does not really treat the de
server particularly especially it's just
another external source of packets and
place that the replicated state machine
may send packets do not very much
different from clients okay so the basic
scheme is that the we assume that these
two replicas the two virtual machines
primary and backup are our exact
replicas some client you know database
client who knows who has some client of
our replicated server sends a request to
the primary and that really takes the
form of a network packet that's what
we're talking about that generates an
interrupt
and this interrupts actually goes to the
virtual machine monitor at least in the
first instance the virtual machine
monitor sees a hot here's the input for
this replicated service and so the
virtual machine monitor does two things
one is it sort of simulates a network
packet arrival interrupt into the
primary guest operating system to
deliver it to the primary copy of the
application and in addition the virtual
machine monitor you know knows that this
is an input to a replicated virtual
machine and it's so it sends back out on
the network a copy of that packet to the
backup virtual machine monitor it's also
guessing and backup virtual machine
monitor knows a hot is a packet for this
particular replicated state machine and
it also fakes a sort of network packet
arrival interrupt at the backup and
delivers the packet so now both the
primary and the back have a copy this
packet they looks at the same input you
know with a lot of details are gonna
process it in the same way and stay
synchronized
course the service is probably going to
reply to the client on the primary the
service will generate a reply packet and
send it on the NIC that the virtual
machine monitor is emulating and then
the virtual machine monitor or will
we'll see that output packet on the
primary they'll actually send the reply
back out on the network to the client
because the backup is running exactly
the same sequence of instructions it
also generates a reply packet back to
the client and sends that reply packet
on its emulated NIC it's the virtual
machine monitor that's emulating that
network interface card and it says aha
you know the virtual machine monitor
says I know this was the backup only the
primary is allowed to generate output
and the virtual machine monitor drops
the reply packet so both of them see
inputs and only the primary generates
outputs as far as terminology goes the
paper calls this stream of input events
and other things other events we'll talk
about from the stream is called the
logging Channel it all goes over the
same network presumably but these events
the primary since the back of our called
log events on the log Channel
where the fault tolerance comes in is
that those the primary crashes what the
backup is going to see is that it stops
getting stuff on the stops getting log
entries a log entry stops getting log
entries on the logging channel and we
know it it turns out that the backup can
expect to get many per second because
one of the things that generates log
entries is periodic timer interrupts in
the in the primary each one of which
turns out every interrupt generates a
log entries into the backup these timer
interrupts are going to happen like 100
times a second so the backups can
certainly expect to see
a lot of chitchat on the logging Channel
if the primaries up if the primary
crashes then the virtual machine
monitored over here will say gosh you
know I haven't received anything on the
logging channel for like a second or
however long the primary must be dead or
or something and in that case when the
backup stop seeing log entries from the
primary the paper the way the paper
freezes it is that the back of goes live
and what that means is that it stops
waiting for these input events on the
logging Channel from the primary and
instead this virtual machine monitor
just lets this backup execute freely
without waiting for without being driven
by input events from the primary the vmm
does something to the network to cause
future client requests to go to the
backup instead of the primary and the
VMM here stops discarding the backup
personnel it's the primary not the
backup stops discarding output from this
virtual machine so now this or machine
directly gets the inputs and there's a
lot of produce output and now our backup
is taken over and similarly you know
that this is less interesting but has to
work correctly
if the backup fails a similar primary
has to use a similar process to abandon
the backup stop sending it events and
just sort of act much more like a single
non replicated server so either one of
them can go live if the other one
appears to be dead stops you know stops
generating network traffic
magic now it depends you know depends on
what the networking technology is I
think with the paper one possibility is
that this is sitting on Ethernet every
physical computer on the Internet or
really every NIC has a 48 bit unique ID
I'm making this up now the it could be
that in fact instead of each physical
computer having a unique ID each virtual
machine does and when the backup takes
over it essentially claims the primary's
Ethernet ID as its own and it starts
saying you know I'm the owner of that ID
and then other people on the ethernet
will start sending us packets that's my
interpretation the designers believed
they had identified all such sources and
for each one of them the primary does
whatever it is you know executes the
random number generator instruction or
takes an interrupt at some time the
backup does not and the back of virtual
machine monitor sort of detects any such
instruction and and intercepts that and
doesn't do it and he said the backup
wheats for an event on the logging
Channel saying this instruction number
you know the random number was whatever
it was on the primary
Edwige
yes yes
yeah the paper hints that they got Intel
to add features to the microprocessor to
support exactly this but they don't say
what it was okay
okay so on that topic the so far that
you know the story is sort of assumed
that as long as the backup to sees the
package from the clients it'll execute
in identically to the primary and that's
actually glossing over some huge and
important details so one problem is that
as a couple of people have mentioned
there are some things that are
non-deterministic now it's not the case
that every single thing that happens in
the computer is a deterministic function
of the contents of the memory of the
computer it is for a sort of straight
line code execution often but certainly
not always so worried about is things
that may happen that are not a strict
function of the current state that is
that might be different if we're not
careful on the primary and backup so
these are sort of non-deterministic
events that may happen so the designers
had to sit down and like figure out what
they all work and here are the ones
here's the kind of stuff they talked
about so one is inputs from external
sources like clients which arrive just
whenever they arrive right they're not
predictable there are no sense in which
the time at which a client request
arrives or its content is a
deterministic function of the services
state because it's not so these actually
this system is really dedicated to a
world in which services only talk over
the network and so the only really
basically the only form of input or
output in this system is supported by
this system seems to be network packets
coming and going so we didn't put
arrives at what that really means it's a
packet
arrives and what a packet really
consists of for us is the data in the
packet plus the interrupt
that's signaled that the packet had
arrived so that's quite important so
when a packet arrives
I'm ordinarily the NIC DMA is the packet
contents into memory and then raises an
interrupt which the operating system
feels and the interrupt happens at some
point in the instruction stream and so
both of those have to look identical on
the primary and backup or else we're
gonna have they're also executions gonna
diverge and so you know the real issue
is when the interrupt occurs exactly at
which instruction the interrupts happen
to occur and better be the same on the
primary in the backup otherwise their
execution is different and their states
are gonna diverge and so we care about
the content of the packet and the timing
of the interrupt and then as a couple of
people have mentioned there's a few
instructions that that behave
differently on different computers or
differently depending on something like
there's maybe a random number generator
instruction there's I get time-of-day
instructions that will yield different
answers have called at different times
and unique ID instructions another huge
source of non determinism which the
paper basically rules out is multi-core
parallelism is a unit process or only
system there's no multi-core in this
world the reason for this is that if it
allowed multi-core then then the service
would be running on multiple cores and
the instructions of the service the rest
of you know the different cores are
interleaved in some way which is not
predictable and so really if we run the
same code on the on the backup in the
server if it's parallel code running on
a multi-core the tubo interleave the
instructions in the two cores in
different ways the hardware will and
that can just cause
different results because you know
supposing the code and the two cores you
know they both asked for a lock on some
data well on the master you know
core one may get the lock before Core 2
on the slave just because of a tiny
timing difference core to may got the
lock first and the you know execution
results are totally different likely to
be totally different if different
threads get the lock
so multi-core is the grim source of
non-determinism man is just totally
outlawed in this papers world and indeed
like as far as I can tell the techniques
are not really applicable the service
can't use multi-core parallel
parallelism the hardware is almost
certainly multi-core parallel but that's
the hardware sitting underneath the
virtual machine monitor the machine that
the virtual machine monitor exposes to
one of the guest operating systems that
runs the primary backup that emulated
virtual machine is a unicorn it's a unit
processor machine in this paper and I'm
guessing there's not an easy way for
them to adapt this design to multi-core
virtual machines
okay so so these are really it's it's
it's these events that go over the
logging channel and so the format of a
log record a log log entry they don't
quite say but I'm guessing that there's
really three things in a log entry
there's the instruction number at which
the event occurred because if you're
delivering an interrupt or you know
input or whatever it better be delivered
at exactly the same place in the primary
backup so we need to know the
instruction number and by instruction
number I mean you know the number of
instructions since the Machine booted
why not the instruction address but like
oh or executing the four billion and
79th instructions since boot so log
entry is going to have instruction
number four an interrupt for input it's
going to be the instruction at which the
interrupt was delivered on the primary
and for a weird instruction like get at
time of day it's going to be the
instruction number of the instruction of
the get time of day or whatever
instruction that was executed on the
primary so that you know the backup
knows where to where to call this event
to occur okay so there's gonna be a type
you know network input whatever a weird
instruction and then there's I'm gonna
be data for a packet arrival it's gonna
be the packet data for one of these
weird instructions it's going to be the
result of the instruction when it was
executed on the primary so that the
backup virtual machine can sort of fake
the instruction and supply that same
result
okay so so as an example the both of
these operating systems guest operating
system assumes requires that the
hardware in this case emulated hardware
virtual machine has a timer that ticks
say a hundred times a second and causes
interrupts to the operating system and
that's how the operating system keeps
track of time it's by counting these
timer interrupts so the way that plays
out those timer notice why they have to
happen at exactly the same place in the
primary and backup otherwise they don't
execute the same no diverge so what
really happens is that the there's
there's a timer on the physical machine
that's running the Ft virtual machine
monitor and the timer on the physical
machine ticks and delivers an interrupt
a timer and up to the virtual machine
monitor on the primary the virtual
machine monitor at you know the
appropriate moment stops the execution
of the primary writes down the
instruction number that it was at you
know instruction since boot and then
delivers sort of fake simulates and
interrupts into the guest operating
system in the primary at that
instruction number saying oh you know
you're emulating the timer Hardware just
ticked
there's the interrupt and then the
primary virtual machine monitor sends
that instruction number which the
interrupt happened you know to the
backup the backup of course it's virtual
machine monitor is also taking timer
interrupts from its physical timer and
it's not giving them it's not giving
it's a real physical timer interrupts to
the to the backup operating system it's
just ignoring them when the law when the
log entry for the primaries timer
interrupts arrives here then the backup
virtual machine monitor will arrange
with the CPU and this requires special
CPU support to cause the physical
machine to interrupt at the same
instruction number
at the timer interrupts tapped into the
primary at that point the virtual
machine monitor gets control again from
the guest and then fakes the timer
interrupts into the backup operating
system now exact exactly the same
instruction number as it occurred on the
primary well yeah so the observation is
that this will this relies on the CPU
having some special hardware in it where
the vmm can tell the hardware CPU please
interrupt a thousand instructions from
now and then the vmm you know where so
that you know it'll interrupt at the
right instruction number the same
instruction as the primary did and then
the vmm just tells the cpu to start X
resume executing again in the backup and
exactly a thousand instructions later
the CPU will force an interrupt into the
virtual machine monitor and that that's
special hardware but it turns out it's
you know on all Intel chips so it's not
it's not that special anymore you know
15 years ago it was exotic now it's
totally normal and it turns out there's
a lot of other uses for it like um if
you want to do profiling you wanna do
CPU time profiling what you'd really
like or one way to do CPU time profiling
is to have the microprocessor interrupt
every thousand instructions right and
this is the hardware that's this
Hardware also this is the same hardware
that would cause the microprocessor to
generate an interrupt every thousand
instructions so it's a very natural sort
of gadget to want in your CPU
all right yes
what if the backup gets ahead of the
primary so you know we standing above
know that oh you know the primary is
about to take an interrupt at the
millionth instruction but the backup is
already you know executed the millionth
and first instruction so it's gonna be
if we let this happen it's gonna be too
late to deliver the interrupts if we let
the backup xu the head of the primary
it's going to be too late to deliver the
interrupts at the same point in the
primary instruction stream and the
backup of the instruction stream so we
cannot let that happen we cannot let the
backup get ahead of the primary in
execution and the way VMware aft does
that is that the the backup virtual
machine monitor it actually keeps a
buffer of waiting events that have
arrived from the primary and it will not
let to the backup execute unless there's
at least one event in that buffer and if
there's one event in that buffer then it
will know from the instruction number
the place at which it's got a force the
backup to stop executing so always
always the backup is executing with the
CPU being told exactly where the next
stopping point the next instruction
number of a stopping point is because
the backup only executes if it has a an
event here that tells it where to stop
next so that means it starts up after
the primary because the backup can't
even start executing until the primary
has generated the first event and that
event has arrived at the backup so the
backup sort of always one event
basically behind the at least one event
behind the primary and if it's slower
for some other whatever reason maybe
there's other stuff running on that
physical machine then the backup might
get you know multiple events behind at
the primary
alright there's a one little piece of
mess about arriving the specific case of
arriving packets ordinarily when a
packet arrives from a network interface
card if we weren't running a virtual
machine the network interface card would
DMA the packet content into the memory
of the computer that it's attached to
sort of as the data arrives from the
network interface card and that means
you know you should never write software
like this but it could be that the
operating system that's running on a
computer might actually see the data of
a packet as its DMA or copied from the
network interface card into memory right
you know this is and you know we don't
know what operating this system is
designed so that it can support any
operating system and cost maybe there is
an operating system that watches
arriving packets in memory as they're
copied into memory so we can't let that
happen because if the primary happens to
be playing that trick it's gonna see you
know if we allowed the network interface
card to directly DMA incoming packets
into the memory of the primary the
primary we don't have any control over
the exact timing of when the network
interface card copies data into memory
and so we're not going to know sort of
at what times the primary did or didn't
observe data from the packet arriving
and so what that means is that in fact
the NIC copies incoming packets into
private memory of the virtual machine
monitor and then the network interface
card interrupts the virtual machine
monitor and says oh a packet has arrived
at that point the virtual machine
monitor will suspend the primary and
remember what instruction number had
suspended at copy the entire packet into
the primaries memory while the primary
suspended and not looking at this copy
and then emulate a network interface
card interrupt into the primary
and then send the packet and the
instruction number to the backup the
backup will also suspend the backup rope
you know virtual machine monitor will
spend the backup at that instruction
number copy the entire packet and again
to the back-up is guaranteed not to be
watching the data arrive and then fakin
interrupts at the same instruction
numbers the primary and this is the
something the bounce buffer mechanism
explained in the paper okay yeah the the
only instructions and that result in
logging channel traffic or are weird
instructions which are rare no its
instructions that might yield a
different result if executed on the
primary and backup like instruction to
get the current time of day or current
processor number or ask how many
instructions have been executed or and
those actually turn out to be relatively
rare there's also one them to get random
tasks when some machines to ask or a
hardware generated random number for
cryptography or something and but those
are not everyday instructions most
instructions like add instructions
they're gonna get the same result on
primary and that go
yeah so the way those get replicated on
the back up is just by forwarding that's
exactly right each network packet just
it's packaged up and forwarded as it is
as a network packet and is interpreted
by the tcp/ip stack on both you know so
I'm expecting 99.99% of the logging
channel traffic to be incoming packets
and only a tiny fraction to be results
from special non-deterministic
instructions and so we can kind of guess
what the traffic load is likely to be
for for a server that serves clients
basically it's a copy of every client
packet and then we'll sort of know what
the logging channel how fast the logging
channel has to be all right so um so
it's worth talking a little bit about
how output works and in this system
really the only what output basically
means only is sending packets that
client send requests in as network
packets the response goes back out as
network packets and there's really no
other form of output as I mentioned the
you know both primary and backup compute
the output packet they want to send and
that sort of asks that simulated mix to
send the packet it's really sent on the
primary and simply discard it the output
packet discarded on the backup okay but
it turns out is a little more
complicated than that so supposing we're
what we're running is a some sort of
simple database server and the operation
the client operation that our database
server supports is increment and ideas
the client sends an increment requests
the database server increments the value
and sends back the new value so maybe on
the primary well let's say everything's
fine so far and the primary backup both
have value 10 in memory and that's the
current value at the counter and some
client on the local area network sends a
you know an increment request to
the primary that packet is you know
delivered to the primary it's you know
it's executed the primary server
software and the primary says oh you
know current values 10 I'm gonna change
to 11 and send a you know response
packet back to the client saying saying
11 as their reply the same request as I
mentioned gonna supposed to be sent to
the backup will also be processed here
it's going to change this 10 to 11 also
generate a reply and we'll throw it away
that's what's supposed to happen the
output however you also need to ask
yourself what happens if there's a
failure at an awkward time if you should
always in this class should always ask
yourself what's the most awkward time to
have a failure and what would happen you
to failure occurred then so suppose the
primary does indeed generate the reply
here back to the client but the client
the primary crashes just after sending
the report its reply to the client and
furthermore and much worse it turns out
that you know this is just a network it
doesn't guarantee to deliver packets
let's suppose this log entry on the
logging channel got dropped also when
the when the primary died so now the
state of play is the client received a
reply saying 11 but the backup did not
get the client request so its state is
still 10 no now the backup takes over
because it's seized the primary is dead
and this client or maybe some other
client sends an increment request a new
backup and now it's really processing
these requests and so the new backup
when it gets the next increment requests
you know it's now going to change its
state to 11 and generate a second 11
response maybe the same client maybe to
a different client which if the clients
compare notes or if it's the same client
it's just obviously cannot have happened
I didn't so you know because we have to
support unmodified software that does
not
damn that there's any funny business of
replication going on that means we do
not have the opportunity to you know you
can imagine the client could go you know
we could change the client to realize
something funny it happened with the
fault tolerance and do I don't know what
but we don't have that option here
because this whole system really only
makes sense if we're running unmodified
software so so this was a big this is a
disaster we can't have let this happen
does anybody remember from the paper how
they prevent this from happening the
output rule yeah so you want to do you
know yeah so the output rules is the
their solution to this problem and the
idea is that the client he's not allowed
to generate you know and generate any
output the primary's not allowed to
generate any output and what we're
talking about now is this output here
until the backup acknowledges that it
has received all log records up to this
point so the real sequence at the
primary then let's now undone crash the
primary go back to them starting at 10
the real sequence now when the output
rule is that the input arrives at the
time the input arrives that's when the
virtual machine monitor sends a copy of
the input to the backup so the the sort
of time at which this log message with
the input is sent is before strictly
before the primary generates the output
sort of obvious then after firing this
log entry off across a network and now
it's heading towards the backup but I'd
have been lost my not the virtual
machine monitor delivers a request to
the primary server software it generates
the output so now the
replicated you know the primary has
actually generated change the state 211
and generated an output packet that says
eleven but the virtual machine monitor
says oh wait a minute we're not allowed
to generate that output until all
previous log records have been
acknowledged by the backup so you know
this is the most recent previous log
message so this output is held by the
virtual machine monitor until the this
log entry containing the input packet
from the client is delivered to the
virtual machine monitor and buffered by
the virtual machine monitor but do not
necessarily execute it it may be just
waiting for the backup to get to that
point in the instruction stream and then
the virtual machine monitor here will
send an active packet back saying yes I
did get that input and when the
acknowledgment comes back only then will
the virtual machine monitor here release
the packet out onto the network and so
the idea is that if the client could
have seen the reply then necessarily the
backup must have seen the request and at
least buffered it and so we no longer
get this weird situation in which a
client can see a reply but then there's
a failure and a cut over and the replica
didn't know anything about that reply if
the you know there's also a situation
maybe this message was lost and if this
log entry was lost and then the primary
crashes well since it hadn't been
delivered so the backup hadn't sent the
act that means if the primary crashed
you know this log entry was brought in
the primary crashed it must have crashed
before the virtual machine monitor or at
least the output packet and prayer for
this client couldn't have gotten the
reply and so it's not in a position to
spot any irregularities they're already
happy with the output rule
brennon see I don't know they don't
paper doesn't mention how the virtual
machine monitor is implemented I mean
it's pretty low level stuff because you
know it's sitting there allocating
memory and figuring page tables and
talking to device drivers and
intercepting instructions and
understanding what instructions the
guest was executing so we're talking
about low-level stuff what language is
written in you know traditionally C or
C++ but I don't actually know okay this
of the primary has to delay at this
point waiting for the backup to say that
it's up to date this is a real
performance thorn in the side of just
about every replication scheme this sort
of synchronous wait where the we can't
let the primary get too far ahead of the
backup because if the primary failed
while it was ahead that would be the
backup lagging lagging behind clients
right so just about every replication
system has this problem that at some
point the primary has to stall waiting
for the backup and it's a real limit on
performance even if the machines are
like side-by-side and adjacent racks
it's still you know we're talking about
a half a millisecond or something to
send messages back and forth with a
primary stalled and if we wanna like
withstand earthquakes or citywide power
failures you know the primary in the
backup have to be in different cities
that's probably five milliseconds apart
every time we produce output if we
replicate in the two replicas in
different city every packet that it
produces this output has to first wait
the five milliseconds or whatever to
have the last log entry get to the
backup and how they need Osment come
back and then we can release a path
packet and you know for sort of low
intensity services that's not a problem
but if we're building a you know
database server that we would like to
you know that if it weren't for this
could process millions of requests per
second then
that's just unbelievably damaging for
performance and this is a big reason why
people you know you know if they
possibly can use a replication scheme
that's operating at a higher level and
kind of understands the semantics of
operations and so it doesn't have to
stall on every packet you know it could
stall on every high level operation or
even notice that well you know read-only
operations don't have to stall at all
it's only right so that just all or
something but you have to there has to
be an application level replication
scheme to to realize that you're
absolutely right so the observation is
that you don't have to stall the
execution of the primary you only have
to hold the output and so maybe that's
not as bad as it could be but
nevertheless it means that every you
know in a service that could otherwise
have responded in a couple of
microseconds to the client you know if
we have to first update the replicas in
the next city we turn to you know 10
micro second interaction into it 10
millisecond interactions possibly if you
have vast numbers of clients submitting
concurrent requests then you may may be
able to maintain high throughput even
with high latency but you have to be
lucky to or very clever designer to get
that
that's a great idea but if you log in
the memory of the primary that log will
disappear when the primary crashes or
that's usual semantics of a server
failing is that you lose everything
inside the box like the contents of
memory or you know if even if you didn't
if the failure is that somebody
unplugged the power cable accidentally
from the primary even if the primary
just has battery backed up RAM or I
don't know what you can't get at it
all right the backup can't get at it so
in fact this system does log the output
and the place it logs it is in the
memory of the backup and in order to
reliably log it there you have to
observe the output rule and wait for the
acknowledgment so it's entirely correct
idea just can't use the primary's memory
for it yes
say it again that's a clever idea I'd
and so the question is maybe input
should go to the primary but output
should come from the backup
I completely haven't thought this
through that might work that
I don't know that's interesting
yeah maybe I will
okay one possibility this does expose
though is that the situation you know
maybe the a primary crashes after its
output is released so the client does
receive the reply then the primary
crashes the backups input is still in
this event buffer in the virtual machine
monitor of the backup it hasn't been
delivered to the actual replicated
service when the backup goes live after
the crash of the primary the backup
first has to consume all of the sort of
log records that are lying around that
it hasn't consumed X it has to catch up
to the primary otherwise it won't take
over with the same state so before the
backup can go live it actually has to
consume all these entries the last entry
is presumably is the request from the
client so the backup will be live after
after it after the interrupt that
delivers the request from the client and
that means that the backup well you know
increment its counter to eleven and then
generate an output packet and since it's
live at this point it will generate the
output packet and the client will get to
eleven replies which is also if it if
that really happened would be anomalous
like possibly not something that could
happen if there was only one server the
good news is that almost certainly or
the almost certainly the client is
talking to this service using TCP and
that this is the request and the
response go back and forth on a TCP
Channel the when the backup takes over
the backup since the state is identical
to the primaries it knows all about that
TCP connection and whether all the
sequence numbers are and whatnot and
when it generates this packet it will
generate it with the same TCP sequence
number as an original packet and the TCP
stack on the client will say oh wait a
minute that's a duplicate packet
we'll discard the duplicate packet at
the TCP level and the user level
software will just never see this
duplicate and so this system really you
know you can view this as a kind of
accidental or clever trick but the fact
is for any replication system where
cutover can happen which is to say
pretty much any replication system it's
essentially impossible to design them in
a way that they are guaranteed not to
generate duplicate output basically you
know you well you can err on either side
I'm not even either not generate the
output at all which would be bad which
would be terrible or you can generate
the output twice on a cutover that's
basically no way to generate it
guaranteed generated only once everybody
errors on the side of possibly
generating duplicate output and that
means that at some level you know the
client side of all replication schemes
need some sort of duplicate detection
scheme here we get to use TCP s that we
didn't have TCP that would have to be
something else maybe application level
sequence numbers or I don't know what
and you'll see all of this and actually
you'll see versions of essentially
everything I've talked about like the
output rule for example in labs 2 & 3
you'll design your own replicated state
machine yes
yes to the first part so the scenario is
the primary sends the reply and then
either the primary send the clothes
packet or the client closes the connect
the TCP connection after it receives the
primary's reply so now there's like no
connection on the client side but there
is a connection on the backup side and
so now the backup so the backup consumes
the very last log entry that as the
input is now live so we're not
responsible for replicating anything at
this point right because the backup now
live there's no other replica as the
primary died so there's no like if if we
don't if the backup fails to execute in
lockstep with the primary that's fine
actually because the primary is is dead
and we do not want to execute in
lockstep with it okay so the primer is
now not it's live it generates an output
on this TCP connection that isn't closed
yet from the backup point of view this
packet arrives with the client on a CCP
connection that doesn't exist anymore
from the clients point of view like no
big whoopee on the client right he's
just going to throw away the packet as
if nothing happened the application
won't no the client may send a reset
something like a TCP error or whatever
packet back to the backup and the backup
does something or other with it but it
doesn't matter because we're not
diverging from anything because there's
no primary to diverge from you can just
handle a stray we said however it likes
and what it'll in fact do is basically
ignore but there's no now the backup has
gone live there's just no we don't owe
anybody anything as far as replication
yeah
well you can bet since the backups
memory image is identical to the
primaries image that they're sending
packets with the very same source TCP
number and they're very same everything
they're sending bit for bit identical
packets you know at this level the
server's don't have IP addresses or for
our purposes the virtual machines you
know the primary in the back up virtual
machines have IP addresses but the the
physical computer and the vmm are
transparent to the network it's not
entirely true but it's basically the
case that the virtual machine monitor in
the physical machine don't really have
identity of their own on the network
because you can configure that then that
way instead these they're not you know
the virtual machine with a sewing
operating system in its own TCP stack it
doesn't IP address underneath there an
address and all this other stuff which
is identical between the primary in the
backup and when it sends a packet it
sends it with the virtual machines IP
address and Ethernet address and those
bits least in my mental model are just
simply passed through on to the local
area network it's exactly what we want
and so I think he doesn't generate
exactly the same packets that the
primary would have generated there's
maybe a little bit of trickery
you know what the we if this is these
are actually plugged into an Ethernet
switch into the physical machines maybe
it wasn't in two different ports of an
Ethernet switch and we'd like the
Ethernet switch to change its mind about
which of these two machines that
delivers packets with replicated
services Ethernet address and so there's
a little bit of funny business there for
the most part they're just generating
identical packets so let me just send
them out
okay so another little detail I've been
glossing over is that I've been assuming
that the primary just fails or the
backup just fails that is fail stop
right but that's not the only option
another very common situation that has
to be dealt with is if the two machines
are still up and running and executing
but there's something funny happen on
the network that causes them not to be
able to talk to each other but to still
be able to talk to some clients so if
that happened if the primary backup
couldn't talk to each other but they
could still talk to the clients they
would both think oh the other replicas
dead I better take over and go live and
so now we have two machines going live
with this service and now you know
they're no longer sending each other log
events or anything they're just
diverging maybe they're accepting
different client inputs and changes are
stayed in different ways so now we have
a split brain disaster if we let the
primary in the backup go live because it
was a network that has some kind of
failure instead of these machines and
the way that this paper solves it I mean
is by appealing to an outside authority
to make the decision about which of the
primary of the backup is allowed to be
live and so it they're you know it turns
out that their storage is actually not
on local disk this almost doesn't matter
but their storage is on some external
disk server and as well as being in this
server as a like totally separate
service there's nothing to do with disks
there this server happens to abort this
test and set test and set service over
the network where you you can send a
test and set request to it and there's
some flag it's keeping in memory and
it'll set the flag and return what the
old value was so both primary and backup
have to sort of acquire this test and
set flag it's a little bit like a lock
in order to go live they both may be
send test and set requests at the same
time to this test and set server the
first one gets back a reply that says oh
the flag used to be zero now it's one
this
second request to arrive the response
from the testing set server is Oh
actually the flag was already one when
your request arrived so so basically
you're not allowed to be primary and so
this this test and set server and we can
think of it as a single machine is the
arbitrator that decides which of the two
should go live if they both think the
other ones dead due to a network
partition any questions about this
mechanism you're busted yeah if the test
and set server should be dead at the
critical moment when and so actually
even if there's not a network partition
under all circumstances in which one or
the other of these wants to go live
because it thinks the others dead even
when the other one really is dead the
one that wants to collide still has to
acquire the test and set lock because
one of like the deep rules of 6:18 for
game is that you cannot tell whether or
another computer is dead or not all you
know is that you stopped receiving
packets from it and you don't know
whether it's because the other computer
is dead or because something has gone
wrong with the network between you and
the other computer so all the backup
ceases well I've stuck in packets maybe
the primary is dead maybe it's live
primary probably sees the same thing so
if there's a network partition they
certainly have to ask the TAT since that
server but since they don't know if it's
a network partition they have to ask the
testing set server regardless of whether
it's a partition or not so anytime
either wants to collide the test and set
server also has to be alive because they
always have to acquire this testing set
lock so the test and set server
sounds like a single point of failure
they were trying to build a replicated
fault tolerant whatever thing but in the
end you know we can't failover unless
unless this is alive so that's a bit of
a bummer
I'm guessing though I'm making a strong
guess that the test and set server is
actually itself a replicated service and
is fault tolerant right it's almost
certainly I mean these people are being
where they're like happy to sell you a
million dollar highly available storage
system that
uses enormous amounts of replication
internally um since the testing set
thing is on there dis server I'm I'm
guessing it's replicated too and the
stuff you'll be doing in lab 2 in lab 3
is more than powerful enough for you to
build your own fault-tolerant test and
set server so this problem can easily be
eliminated